i'm here with nate silver the author of
the signal
and the noise why so many predictions
fail but some don't he's also known for
the 538 blog the new york times which
accurately predict the results in all 50
states for the 2012 presidential
election nate thanks for being here yeah
thank you conan uh a lot of questions
first of all when we called and asked
you
if you'd come here one of the first
things you said was you wouldn't be
inviting me
if i had my predictions had been
incorrect probably probably not
statistically unlikely unlikely yeah
that's probably about three to four
percent i'd be doing it well we had we
had romney with a with a nine percent
chance of winning on election day right
because there had been toward the end of
the race you saw obama gaining ground in
the polls whether because of hurricane
sandy or the relatively good jobs
reports that we had um but it was a
close election for
for a while right and it wound up being
close i mean obama did not win by a
landslide uh by any means whatsoever um
but still it's you know i always make
the sports analogy because i i used to
cover baseball before i get into
politics right where if a team enters
the ninth inning with with the one run
lead and they have a good closer they're
usually going to win it's a close game
not any guarantee um but they have a
bigger edge than you might think from it
being a 1-1 game or a close game so the
going into the election the night before
obama versus romney
you said that the president had a 91
percent chance
of winning so
uh you were quite confident that that
was going to be the result
if you were watching the media the way i
was
in the days leading up to the election
forget the months leading up to election
but sure but the day is leading up to
the election that it's not the
impression
that anybody had it was thought of as a
very close race i'm in media i talk to a
lot of people in media
many people were convinced this could go
late into the night
so
why why does the media do that well if
they do it on purpose i i think to some
extent sure i mean look at their look at
their incentives really right the
incentives are to to get better ratings
right and to sell more newspapers get
more traffic on your website and you say
hey it's right down to the wire gonna
come down to the last vote that's a
better it's a better story than when you
have oh this one candidate's probably
going to win he's ahead in all the swing
states right even in 2008 which was much
less close than this year um you had the
four pundits in the mclaughlin group the
day before the election said it was too
close to call right and you really you
know i mean there was no way it was too
close to call you had uh obama ahead of
mccain by by seven or eight points and
in every swing state pretty much okay
and we're gonna talk about there's noise
it's what you talk about in your book
the signal and the noise we live in an
era where there's more noise than
there's ever been before right and noise
is a distraction and
obviously
what you talk about in the book is that
nothing helps more than data the more
data you can have often the better your
prediction will be
the problem is we live in an era where
there's
tons of data you just can't
discern what's reliable what's not
reliable that's right so if you have
more data it should make your life
easier it's more information about a
problem and so you can make a better
decision but people can have
information overload sometimes where
they don't know how to process this
information they haven't really trained
themselves to do that or or worse if you
have 400 different cable channels then
you have a lot of choice for how you
consume your information right yeah i'm
just talking about before a lot of those
choices are not really giving you the
most accurate picture that they can be
giving you a particular set of
information that may mislead you right
if you really were based on who they
think is watching probably something
who's watching if you really were
watching fox news every day during the
campaign or going to the drudge report
say right then you would see plenty of
polls showing romney uh ahead or tie
whatever else because surging yeah
because they would cherry pick the three
poles out of 30 or 40 that would come
out that day and highlight and highlight
those three right so if you were really
in that bubble what you're not doing i'm
someone who i do go ahead and uh and i
watch fox news and msnbc and i read
conservative blogs and liberal blogs
it's important i think to do that but
people uh it's so easy now just kind of
stay in your own little bubble and never
venture outside of it and it seems like
people are doing that more and more
nowadays well i i call that preaching to
the choir
that's what i think most entertainment
most media is these days is that you can
have a satellite channel with 85 or 150
different channels on it and you can
just listen to the music that you're
comfortable with you're never confronted
with anything that you're not
comfortable with you can
choose to watch the news that you're
comfortable with you can choose to hear
the opinions that you're comfortable
with so what i think is that nobody's
changing anybody's minds everybody's
talking to
the people that agree with them and no
one's stepping outside of their little
cubicle so and there are various ways to
measure partisanship you can for example
look at how often democrats and
republicans agree on anything in in the
congress and uh it's becoming i mean
there's been less and less partisan
agreement um since about 1970 or 1980
and that coincides with the rise of of
cable television it might just be a
coincidence but i think it's it's uh
where people no longer have to actually
go and have a civil debate and iron out
their differences they can just kind of
retreat to their corners a lot more i
think it's it's pretty it's pretty
dangerous for uh for the democracy
frankly well i think about say 1968 or i
think 68 ted offensive
and walter cronkite goes on the news and
he pretty much looks into the camera and
says i
no longer believe that this war is
winnable
and
uh
it was a shocking moment and lyndon
johnson saw that and said we just lost
walter cronkite this is debacle
wouldn't happen anymore because walter
cronkite was talking to
liberals and conservatives
you know and
he was talking to america nobody i don't
think anybody's talking to america
anymore now there'd be walter cronkite's
people wouldn't probably know walter
cronkite's opinion and be comfortable
with it but nobody who's uncomfortable
with walter cronkite's opinion is going
to be even watching him or carrying what
he thinks yeah if people say this is the
other unfortunate thing right where if
you say something that that people don't
like they assume you're on the other
team right uh they assume that you're
some partisan hack right and i think
look i think journalists have political
views and ought to have political views
if you're if you're covering uh a field
and you don't have some opinions about
it's a little odd i think right yeah
it's kind of sociopathic if you have no
feelings whatsoever about the about
about the field that you're studying um
but at the same time i think it is
possible to be a
to try and be honest broker at least
right and say look i'm delivering the
data to you the best i can and and you
know willing to back it up with it with
showing your work and defending your
case and that's what they do at uh at
harvard business school for example
right is uh it's all about they'll give
you some hypothetical or sometimes some
real uh business to study right you say
well here's what here's what i do and
the professor doesn't care about that
part as much as the next part which is
when he says well defend your ideas
right here are five critiques i came up
with your ideas defend them and we don't
get that level of depth very often
certainly not with the kind of skimming
the surface cable news punditry right
where um where people say a lot of
things that aren't really very
defensible if they had to be a little
bit deeper and they hope anyone kind of
calls them on on wanting to to read the
fine print and i'm more of a detail
oriented guy i think sometimes it's so
easy to get
different sips of information now that
we don't we forget that you lose
something when you make an approximation
or an abstraction um you know it's not
as good as as flushing things out at
greater length i think well you were
chillingly correct on election
day
uh you were right about uh the outcome
for president obama you were also
right about all these senate races you
got one senate race wrong we had two
wrong actually you had two wrong yeah um
in north dakota we had the democrat with
only an eight percent chance or nine
percent chance of winning and and she
won which goes to show you that we put
those probabilities in there for for a
reason it's just like you know that uh
in the ncaa tournament you would not
want to bet on the 15 seed to beat the
two seed in the opening round but you
know what's going to happen
one out of 15 times or so or one out of
20 well it's one of the it's one of the
tricks if you say uh that this is a
you know uh
you have a 99 chance
of being fine a lot of people take that
to mean then i'm perfectly safe exactly
you need to point out well no there
actually is a one percent chance yeah
that you might be killed if uh if my
airplane back to new york if they told
me that nate there's a 99 chance that
the plane won't crash then there's no
way to get on that airplane right
especially when you find out that it's
flying 200 flights that week yeah then
you want no part of it
all right here's a question i have um
elections are probably some of the most
dramatic moments in the history of our
country
there's a danger
that you're taking the fun out of them
there's a danger that yeah that that the
great photograph of truman holding up
the newspaper
uh dewey defeats truman
uh and
the entire nation had it completely
wrong
is that possible anymore is it possible
uh for the news media or have we gotten
to a point where we've broken it down
there's so much data it's so closely
studied that we're going to have no more
dramatic election nights oh no we'll
have we'll have a lot of dramatic
elections i think i mean look at the
primaries for example where the polls
did not do
very well this year or in 2008 you had
plenty of states where hillary clinton
was supposed to to you know have her
sayonara after new hampshire right and
said she came back to win you had this
epic primary battle going back and forth
for for months and months right so those
it's you know again i go back to the
sports analogy yet again but um the fact
that you can you have some sense of the
cisco likelihood of an underdog winning
a ncaa tournament doesn't make it any
less fun
i don't think really right yeah i i
guess you know i'm thinking about
historically
you have campaigns
i don't know if your model would
maybe you could tell me would it have
worked in the past i know you've looked
at some past elections but 1980 is an
intriguing year because you have reagan
carter carter's the incumbent
reagan's behind for quite a while and
then has
after a great debate performance
a surge and uh
coming into the election and then uh
very dramatically wins the election
would would that be possible today would
you be able to would you be able to
track that do you think that that would
so would an election like that happen
again would your model have worked in
1980 so i'll give you a slightly
technical answer okay which is
and i'll pretend to understand
so the model looks at both polls and
economic data and the night's native
economy was was was really really bad um
with nine or ten percent inflation with
unemployment higher than it was right
last year um you know people think oh
it's a slow recovery now but this was a
a catastrophic kind of recession right
in the middle of the election year that
was very scary for people so under those
conditions you would think that uh the
incumbent would have a tough time and
that once reagan kind of got on the
stage and introduced himself as a
competent alternative then he might have
done pretty well so i think that
election is one where you say well yeah
there's a point at which the polls click
in and become more reliable when you
have a a county who was kind of
controversial to that point people knew
reagan maybe is an actor maybe as
governor of california but he had run as
the conservative alternative to uh to
jerry ford and in 76 and now is
repositioning himself um toward the
center to be someone more presidential
and so once that clicked in then he had
a very good argument to make on his
behalf i also think
and your statistics would probably bear
this out anytime a challenger gets
shares a stage
with a president
you always see the close the the polls
start to tighten a little bit yeah
because once they are standing in the
same shot
two shot with these president united
states and they've managed to show up
they're dressed they're not drunk
they're not wearing a silly hat
immediately people start to say okay
this is a this is a reasonable
alternative i'm still not sure i'll vote
for this person but
it's almost a human psychology takes
over i i think so i mean although not
maybe if rick perry had been the gop
candidate instead of
we wouldn't see what happened but but i
think it's also the incumbent is
is rusty a lot of time right and you get
the sense that so i've done enough
things where you have to go and and talk
to people now right you're under
pressure to perform right um and people
can tell when you don't want to when you
don't want to be there right when you
feel like you're wasting your time right
and obama in that first debate seemed
like he didn't want to be
on that stage right and that's just kind
of that intangible impression that
conveys um i think was was pretty
damaging to him right he kind of didn't
bother to show up for for the job
interview and it wasn't like he made
some gap there was not really any one
sound bite from that first debate that
was replayed over and over again it was
just kind of the artistic impression
part of it kind of that um that was
wrong somehow on the other hand it kind
of meant that the bar was was lower for
him in the last two debates as well
right if he just that was his chance to
sir the media had its story that it
wanted to write then probably which is
obama surges back that's right he needed
to give them the opportunity to write
that story yeah you can see i mean so i
think there were there were reasons
there were reasons after the convention
where you had this bounce for obama
right you could kind of tell that the
media was getting tired of of that story
right was ready to have another shift in
momentum right and so and romney
provided that moment so i think
everything gets a little bit exaggerated
by by the way campaigns are covered
momentum basically means that the press
is is piling on in one direction at some
points during the campaign it was
helpful to obama at some point it was
helpful uh to romney but you do have
this kind of pylon effect that um that
can make these kind of one-off events
have have legs and last for for weeks
and weeks as far as the way the coverage
goes the um
a lot of people are wondering i know i'm
wondering
that
uh
it was reported
that the romney camp really thought they
were going to win now i don't know
in a world of spin counter spin counter
counter spin are they just saying that
to project an image do you believe the
romney camp really thought went into
election day thinking they were going to
win i believe they wanted the press to
think they thought that right but in in
reality was mitt romney stunned that he
did not win was he surprised was he
shocked or was did someone quietly take
him aside on election day and say
well if this was so this wasn't this
wasn't 1984. if we you know where walter
mondale you know he would have had a
million to one chance and romney in our
estimation had a 10-1 chance those 10-1
things do do come up sometimes right um
like if romney was a good
businessman right and was looking at his
campaign as a business then he would
have realized that he had had a bad last
quarter so to speak right where the
polls had shifted toward obama or last
week's campaign he hadn't really closed
the deficit romney hadn't in the swing
states so um so he ought to have known
but for any of us and especially if
you're in a campaign bubble doing honest
self-assessment is is really really
difficult right
and you don't want to be the pollster or
the strategist who comes up to romney
and says oh you're probably gonna you're
probably gonna lose right um so i don't
know i don't know when i when i talked
to the campaign a couple of months
before um this kind of surge they had
after the debate and they seemed to have
a pretty realistic view of of where they
stood but i think the closer you get to
election day the more uh you get in the
bubble the more what you start off kind
of i mean i think you have this chain
where you start off kind of spinning
things to people right and then you
start to
believe it right you hear your own noise
it's it's a it's a feedback loop yeah
you're making the noise you start to
hear the noise that you're making you
start to believe the noise you're making
and then you start making more of that
noise absolutely right and if you're the
candidate then it's hard to uh to get
out and talk to to real people right
where you're protected both for reasons
of of security and just the people that
you're around you know one thing that
was different this year is that you have
more and more fundraisers with this kind
of super pac crowd right and you know i
think that might have an effect on on
the way the candidates approach the the
campaign right where the average person
that mitt romney was talking to was
someone who was a a very big republican
partisan uh probably had a lot of money
right so he wasn't necessarily hearing
from from the common folks i guess as
much nor nor as president was obama it's
very difficult to do as well what
happens is the crowds are selected and
then they're only playing for audiences
that love them yeah all performers as a
performer i love that but you can get a
false positive well so i went to uh to
new hampshire for the primaries and
that's different because new hampshire
is a tradition that you know you might
not be planning to vote for uh for newt
gingrich or mitt romney rick santorum
but they're open events right and so
you'd have some some hostile questioning
from from the audience and that's very
interesting to see that you know rick
santorum i saw an event where he was
questioned on on gay marriage by a
number of of young kind of republicans
who felt very different on that issue
than than he did right and that was
fascinating to see that and uh did he
respond well to it he responded he tried
to respond right but he didn't i mean he
didn't have it he was off his talking
points it was interesting to see how
well a politician improvises when when
he's off his talking points you know the
kind of the true naturals uh the
clintons and and the reagans right we'll
find some way to do it it is very much
like a performance yes i imagine right
where maybe you tell a joke you can
deflect things that way or maybe you
just kind of get what the person's
really asking or find some way to defuse
a situation um you know romney wasn't
bad when he had these kind of set pieces
like the like the debates um but he was
someone who's used i think to being in
in control very much as someone who was
successful at a very early age and of
course it's great to be successful and
business is a different world it's a
different world right um and this is not
a business where you're you're like
manufacturing widgets or something it's
a business where you're dealing with
investments and and capital it's kind of
a boardroom kind of a business right um
and so it's not quite like you're out
there dealing with people on the factory
line yeah and things like that
a lot of people myself included are
wondering
uh
one of the reasons i think that you
could be so accurate with your
predictions is that you can focus in on
these swing states you can really zero
in on them
and i'm curious in 2016 ohio florida are
we are we going to be back at the same
story again pretty much i think i mean
you pretty much have and are we are we
stuck with ohio and florida well you
could have virginia in colorado right
the new breed of swing states right but
it's it's you're not going to have uh
you're not going to have
texas or or alaska or something suddenly
become a swing state these things are
pretty slow moving over the course of
many years you know it used to be that
uh that vermont
and maine were the most republican
states
in the country right so you have this
kind of glacial change almost like the
continent's moving right and over the
course of of many years then then there
can be shifts but but four years at a
time so 2016 you think ohio florida
those are still the maps we're still
looking at those two states on election
night and breaking it down precinct by
precinct unless you have some radically
unexpected candidate being nominated
right that's my next question yeah have
you thought at all if chris christie
were to run for president in 2016
his popularity is such that suddenly new
jersey which has traditionally been a
democratic state for quite a while
that they vote for chris christie if
he's running you could right you could
uh might be your whole model that's
right so if you do have a candidate who
um uh but president county you get
usually it's about a seven point home
state boost right it's like home court
advantage and so that could potentially
make new jersey more competitive that's
right if you had a christie running or
just in general the fact that if you had
someone who it's been a while since we
had someone running from the kind of
northeastern moderate wing of the
republican party um so that's kind of an
untested hypothesis so to speak and that
could be a little different right um
where maybe you would put states like
like maine for example back and play
maine uh after long ago was republican
but then became a swing site for many
years and hasn't been very much
competitive at all but if you had a
republican who was more moderate on on
social issues right um and still
fiscally conservative then you'd have a
different template than you do right now
where they're kind of doubling down on
every brand of conservatism and so it
becomes very polarized and partisan and
predictable basically based on whether
you live near a coast or a city you vote
democrat or otherwise you vote
republican okay so let's uh create a
hypothetical situation where the
republican party uh you are partisan or
the republican party has made you
partisan because they've come to you and
they're paying you as their consultant
would you advise what would your advice
to them be
for a republican candidate in 2016 who
has the greatest likelihood of defeating
a democratic well i think someone like a
christie would be a pretty decent
messenger potentially i think a
jeb bush but these might be the people
that i personally think are are seem
like they're
reasonable and intelligent people and
have a forward-looking view for whether
they're public parties what i'm trying
to get you to do is do what you advocate
which is divorce yourself from that yeah
statistically if you were to look at do
you think that if you would a model be
able to show you that the republican
party needs to move closer to the center
the republican party needs to
uh close the gap with african-americans
hispanics is that something that i'm
well here's the time i mean the math is
pretty if you look at uh
so under the age of 30 40 of voters in
the age of 30 were minorities right
that's what the future is going to look
like by the way half people under 18
they're not voting yet in this country
are are non-white now right um so what
parties should do classically is as you
adjust to that so yes of course you're
going to shift to the center a little
bit on on immigration and and gay
marriage which are two issues where the
younger cohort feels much differently
than um than older voters do right maybe
uh drug legalization a few other issues
like that right
that's what a rational political party
would do and if it does that then the
gop look i mean romney ran against an
incumbent who at the end of the day had
a 50 approval rating and usually get
reelected with that and um and obama has
a very good campaign operation it's
tough to beat an incumbent and romney
still got 47
of the vote right you know it's not that
far from from 50 and so um so there's a
rational road forward
for the republican party and yeah of
course it's going to involve moderating
on on some select issues and changing
your tone a little bit right and being a
little bit more inclusive as a party if
they don't do that then they could be in
the wilderness for for some period of
time um right i'm oddly optimistic for
some reason about their ability to take
four years and and maybe finally get it
right
i was just enjoying that you were
advocating drug legalization while
wearing a cookie monster t-shirt well
thank you
i just enjoyed that let's move on uh to
other areas outside of politics because
the signal and the noise is about so
much more
um
you know one of the things that
fascinates me as you discuss
data in this book the value of data the
double-edged nature
of data
a lot of data can be a great thing
because if you have it in certain areas
it can really help we have much more
data now about the weather you talk
about the weather
and you say that weather forecasting has
improved
tremendously yeah in the last 20 years
because we have more data at the same
time
too much data is a problem
too much data in the wrong hands is is a
problem certainly and again you look at
the kind of political pundits where it's
almost like the more information they
get the more ability they have to to
spin and mislead uh mislead you and and
kind of not tell the whole truth and
sherry pick their facts a little bit
more or if you go back to the days of of
the printing press i talked about in the
book that was kind of the original
information technology explosions all of
a sudden people had had books when it
used to take literally twenty thousand
dollars in today's dollars to transcribe
a book by hand and now you had a machine
that could do it uh hundreds of times
cheaper than that right gutenberg
figures out a way for people to have
books suddenly more and more people have
books
and that's when you start to see as you
point out in the book more religious
wars yeah right there's more violence
because more people can disseminate
their opinions like this disagrees with
your idea right you're wrong right and
all of a sudden it's like when you know
it's like a a comment thread on the
internet or something for the first time
right people really go after one another
and they and they feel they have more
proof of their ideas now right and so
yeah you you had uh um the process and
reformation um uh triggered in part by
the printing press and the process
reformation um entail for some period of
time a lot of holy wars all throughout
europe for you've got interesting you've
got the inquisition you have terrible
violence misery
and
it's funny because clearly books are a
great thing but of course the books are
great but you should have a graph that
shows the minute gutenberg starts
printing books and the more the average
person can afford a book uh the violence
and the rewards go through the roof yeah
so um
i don't know how to feel about that now
we're we're definitely living in an age
of a lot of information i had a personal
experience with this
uh when i first started out as a
television performer in 93
and there was a lot of noise just about
me uh taking over this television show
and who is this guy and every day i
would get
once a week we'd get these ratings about
how we did the week before
and sometimes people would
say you know your number dropped a
little bit or you didn't start with as
many viewers or you lost some so maybe
you shouldn't do
that comedy piece at the beginning of
the show and i would be thinking that
comedy piece felt good and the audience
liked it and it felt good and they'd say
yeah you probably shouldn't do that
it took a while and i'm not in your
field but at one point i found out that
the sample size for a show that's on at
12 35 at night and i don't know if it's
changed now but the sample size was tiny
for the for the nielsen rating so my
rating was being affected by
i don't know three people the flu is
going around and three people didn't
feel maybe you had a lakers game that
went to overtime right exactly there
were things and and i thought
at a certain point i said i'm getting
too much noise what i need to really
listen to is
what feels right to me that felt funny
that felt good there was a good flow
but i became very aware at that point
that i was getting information that was
not helping me that's not making the
show better it wasn't well and look and
believe me there are times when uh
when information is misleading and used
to make bad decisions then it can be
worse than no information right i think
the way that uh that education is
occurring nowadays where you have a lot
of teachers who are teaching to these
standardized tests right right which are
are not necessarily tests developed to
to improve critical thinking skills
right or analytical skills but instead
to memorize a bunch of
facts and so forth right so now you have
these objective measurements of teacher
performance that don't necessarily
benefit either the teachers or the
children as much it's the same thing you
talk about in your book in the financial
sector
nobody thought about this at the time i
certainly didn't know about it i didn't
know that moody's and standard employers
were being paid that that they were
making money
to give their ratings and that the
greater volume of rating that they gave
the more money they would make
it's the same thing you say once the
system
is tainted
gee if we can get kids to answer these
questions correctly on a standardized
test it's better for our school and for
our jobs right it's the same thing
uh all these uh
mortgage-backed securities are getting
triple-a ratings
but because it benefits
the ratings companies to do that and so
what happened was the information we
were getting
and like like a sap i thought that's
triple a rated sorry trust yeah we all
become children at a certain point i
trust that dad or mom is taking care of
stuff i thought a triple a rating
uh was a man that was really vetted we
now know that that was nothing could be
further from the truth and it's tricky i
mean we're learning that we have to be
skeptical of a lot of different
institutions right including government
and business and many different things
right and at what point can you be
um have healthy skepticism without
becoming a conspiracy
virus kind of nut case right
but i think if people start from a
position of of of not taking things at
face value right up to a point at least
right when you hear something that a
political reporter says that they heard
from a campaign like that's a good
example of something which you shouldn't
necessarily take uh at face value it's
intended as spin yes the best reporters
can can sort through that and give you
some nugget of truth um but people are
are are much too willing to take dubious
information um or to take unprecedented
situations and and not really kind of
apply their own filter of common sense
and and so forth well here's the bigger
problem uh
i don't know what you're feeling is on
uh nicholas talib but
when i started reading him a while ago
he introduced me to this idea that
seemed attractive to me which is that
the human brain is inherently flawed you
know and i and i liked
i found it helpful to remember
that
we are flawed our thinking is flawed
that uh our brain and that we are
constantly and i think this is a big
part of your work is
working to counteract
the flaws
of the human brain yeah that we love to
see patterns even if there aren't
patterns there we love
there are certain ways of thinking that
really benefited us when we were trying
to escape a leopard uh
when we were hiding in a cave not so
much now now it can get us into trouble
and so it's trying to counteract the
organic flaws that are in our mind well
do you subscribe absolutely right i mean
we're human beings are very smart
creatures right um but relatives the
overall amount of information in the
universe right i mean that's the kind of
crazy thing about it right someone says
well my subjective point of view you
know it's truthful and you guys are all
wrong right i mean you know how can you
say that when when you're just one
person that's like literally this
gigantic
universe right it demands i think some
uh some humility and you look at the way
we did things uh you know how we treat
disease 300 years ago with leeches or
whatever now right and probably 300
years from now they'll think that
chemotherapy is something incredibly
barbaric barbaric and primitive where
you make someone sick in order to make
them healthy again right it'll be seen
as barbaric potentially um and you know
and if you follow the history of of
knowledge and the history of science and
then it is humbling as cool as we think
that our age is now the guarantee is
that we're gonna have more and more
technological progress some ways that we
frankly can't anticipate very well well
we're going to have
they're going to finish mapping the
human genome yeah and i think talk about
computer analysis
statistics
people were very close to a time when a
baby's born you prick their finger you
get a sample of their blood and you find
out that yeah you're going to have colon
cancer yeah when you're 55 what does
that mean
and and what are the choices that we
make then so talk about more data we're
going to have a lot we're only going to
have more and more data well see but
there's the thing there i said that
where you kind of take the fun
out of it right is the fun of getting
colon cancer 55
you're right no but yeah
but some people like to do the 23andme
things whatever where you have your
you're the odds of every different
design i i do think there are people
need some some peace of mind and by the
way you know the reason that we have we
forget things um you know having better
memory is helpful on balance but
forgetting things is also an
evolutionary response right to allow our
emotions to process uh through difficult
periods right um and so that's part of
the issue is that our brains have many
different modes that operate in and it's
not it's not always in scientific
analytical mode right sometimes it's in
emotional rage mode right and that can
cloud your judgment potentially though
it's also useful for for different
reasons um but you know people need to
be just more more critical of of
themselves and you know trusting your
gut sounds very alluring and and sexy
right like oh just kind of trust your
gut instinct and have faith in yourself
right um it sounds very romantic idea
but um but people who who use that kind
of judgment when they're processing
through
too much information through very
difficult problems tend not to do as
well as those who who slow down and take
their time to to parse through the facts
right well
i'm curious about
baseball obviously
sports big part of your life baseball uh
was changed forever
by
the whole moneyball uh
approach to to baseball that was
chronicled by by michael lewis and
there's a
it seems that baseball works well in
this world because there's a lot of data
there's a lot and it's pretty controlled
it's the the diamond they're pretty much
the parameters of the field where
they're playing um
and
that feels like a world that responds
well to data yeah and baseball one kind
of takes turns right it's this guy's
chance at bat and hits the ball one
player and the player throws the other
player right see these discrete elements
that you can quantify
a lot easier than you can in a sport
like like football for example you have
22 players on the field who are in
motion together um basketball somewhere
in between where right uh where kaiser
kind of standing around but pushing for
the rebound of everything else and
basketball you've seen some progress
with with using statistics but baseball
is this kind of perfect laboratory
environment to study how statistics work
and how probability works and how
randomness works and so a lot of people
uh i think you know basically i think
they should
have kids who are learning statistics
like just go study baseball right
instead of learning the theory get your
hands uh have a hands-on experience with
you know try and build like a rotisserie
baseball team or something right people
like i'm joking when i say so i think it
would like literally help kids learn
more just like when you're actually um
trying to learn about the english
language you read you read books right
you experience things you immerse
yourself in that culture if you're
trying to learn spanish you you go to
mexico you go to spain you immerse
yourself that's right um instead of just
saying well here's a here's a pronoun
right and here's a no you kind of learn
it through through
through feeling it out right it's clear
also that you're a believer in putting
your money where your mouth is that that
helps that betting
on whether it's your your uh rotisserie
league or uh putting a little money down
on baseball gets you
or when you're playing poker
gets you immersed
in probability in a way that's more
visceral than if you were just looking
at it on the page yeah it's hard to play
poker if you don't have any money
right online right you don't have any as
many incentives to play to play
seriously right and that's and that's
the good thing about business by the way
i'm not like the biggest rah-rah free
market guy i think it's it's the least
worst system that we have but the one
good thing about business is that they
are putting their money on their line if
you have a dumb idea in business that
might sound good in the boardroom you
might persuade people but if the product
doesn't sell then it's not going to do a
lot of good in the long run um so uh you
know investors even put their money
where their mouth is and poker players
do for some reason it's seen as very odd
if you wanted um in news coverage say
like hey look you know i believe in the
announce that we're doing and be willing
to to make a gentlemanly wager on it
then it's like oh we can't we can't do
that but i think i think it has to with
the clash between um what journalists
think of as as objectivity and what and
what kind of scientists might or what
what poker players might or or how other
people might approach the problem where
we're in political journals and
objective just means that um that you
recite each side's talking points for
about the same amount of time is kind of
this this workaround that developed in
practice right um whereas the way i
define objectivity basically means being
true it means that there's a world
outside of the way i view things right
and when we have a test if we make a
prediction we're testing how well does
my sense of how this external world
looks correspond to the genuine article
um and if you're someone who is always
making bad predictions that means your
subjective filters are distorting this
objective reality a lot and so i think
that was what was uh
regardless of your politics the election
day 2012
was nice to have a result we finally
waited all this time we got a result
obviously gratifying for you because you
called it
but
all these pundits were saying all kinds
of things it was on tapes you could go
back and look at it and then
the uh the election happens and you get
your result and i think that's the
that's the release of baseball poker you
get your result and in business which
leads me to my next question
uh financial crisis
government steps in
and intervenes
which in a way is
skewing the game a little bit and i
don't know how you you know in in terms
of
uh people talk about moral hazard does
that mean that sure as we move forward
if this really is a game if you and i
are playing poker and it's a real game
and you lose
and i suddenly slide some of my chips
over to you we're changing the whole
framework of the game look capitalism is
very very good at taking advantage of
opportunities in the system and by the
way with with the internet now it kind
of is the same thing right where if
there's something that's that's going
wrong if someone else is not doing
something in the marketplace where
there's money to made then someone else
will will step in and fill that vacuum
right but that means if you design
systems that have bad incentives and and
bad rules and you can kind of almost
guarantee that that someone will be
willing to trade these financial
instruments that that are risky and that
ultimately um that the taxpayer is
bearing some of the risk unless you
regulate them in the right way and there
is such a thing as too much regulation i
absolutely believe right but um but at
the same time yeah you know we shouldn't
be we shouldn't be shocked when when uh
when capitalism figures out how to how
to sell snake oil right um between
everyone in the world if someone doesn't
do it then someone else will step in and
and fill that void potentially and so
you can you know it's it's uh i'm not
saying the finance crisis was
predictable but it's predictable that um
that you're going to have
that the update for risk will move up
and down and that um and that you'll
have companies that are are very
aggressive about pursuing the next big
commodity that may or may not be right
and you know by the way you know i think
that in the end that you need
risk-taking ability i i just wish there
were a way that the taxpayer is is more
insulated from that potentially well you
talk about in the mortgage crisis for
every
i think the first person that i read who
made this point for every one dollar
in mortgage
the financial markets were making fifty
dollars in side bets yeah yeah
which
uh and a lot of these side bets are
being made in milliseconds because we
live in this computerized world
so when you realize we were leveraged to
that point
uh you'd think that it would have been
predictable that this has to fall apart
at some point well and of course it's
always easier after the fact right to go
back and say uh oh well of course this
is kind of this is what happened but
look i mean a lot of people
understood that the housing bubble was
going on while it was going on if you go
if you went to vegas at any point during
during the housing bubble right you
could see houses being built as far as
you could see and it's it's it's in
desert with a town it's a one industry
town right or florida or florida right
um not places where where land was
inherently scarce necessarily right um
it was just pure speculation but if you
look there people who actually owned
homes that increased only slightly i
think from like 56 to 59 percent right
which meant that was people speculators
buying second and third or 20 and 30
properties um and it wasn't really tied
to a fundamental increase in in
prosperity like you had during the 50s
for example um but um the people you
know if you see the green arrows going
up on on on cnbc you see housing prices
going up it's very hard to to resist
that right your instinct's like this is
good i'm going to keep i want to be part
of this i want to be part of this ride
the hot stream people who are worried
that if i don't buy a home now then
it'll be impossible to afford one in in
10 years keeping up with the joneses
kind of thing um and then it all comes
crashing down you know in the end in the
end i think uh you know people usually
get what's coming to them if they make
bad bets but it can take it can take
years or decades sometimes um and if you
were someone who uh you know bought um
some of these crappy tech stocks for
example during during the dot-com boom
right um yes they eventually crashed but
if you had cashed out on just the right
day you would have made four or five
times your money if you had if you were
that impression about it in advance
uh global warming i wanted to ask you
about that's uh we obviously have data
but do we have enough data to make a
real prediction where do you where are
you on global warming here's what i'd
say i think if you look at what the un
reports actually say right they have
different levels of of certainty um and
the kind of first thing they said and
the first part they did in 1990s all i
said
was that hey we know the greenhouse
effect exists and it's going to make the
planet warmer right and in some ways
it's kind of all
all you need to know really right it's
when you get to the specificity of
saying well what's this exact scenario
for when will you know when will it be
flooding in in lower manhattan or how
will this um jungle be affected right
that's stuff there's a lot of
uncertainty about it there's also a lot
of hyperbole obviously magazines love to
put the statue of liberty underwater
right on the cover
as if to say we're 25 years away from
you need to take a rowboat to get to
your third floor
and that's where obviously there's a lot
of
emotion taking over there's a lot of
yeah in the 1970s you had uh you had uh
newsweek i think published a cover story
on now we're gonna have the next great
ice age right um and now people say well
that proves that uh that you know
climate scientists don't know what
they're talking about right in fact that
was not a minority that was a minority
view right there were one or two papers
on that it's more or less about the way
the press covers this stuff right where
um this piece of this journal article
which was not mainstream science really
um it's a lot more interesting for a
cover story than than one that says well
we're not sure we probably the
greenhouse effect will probably get
warmer but it'll be 20 or 30 years from
now right which is kind of consensus
feedback then but that doesn't sell it
doesn't sell magazines whereas the next
ice age and the river thames freezing
over and everything else
does
well it's the famous story of the
any doctor that wants to get on the
evening news
needs to say children are going to die
yeah yeah if they want it you know
that's what they need to say and if they
say well it's complicated and you know
my father is an infectious disease
scientist and
whenever a news crew would come by and
he'd talk to them a local news crew he'd
say well you know say what about this
outbreak well it's given nuance
you know it's interesting you know
and they would film them for a while and
they would leave and he would say hey
i'm going to be on the news tonight and
we would watch and he wouldn't be on the
news they had found a different guy of
course you're all dead yeah everybody's
dead within a 50-mile radius dead dead
dead and so
uh that's uh obviously an issue is that
we're
we we like stories we like dramatic
stories
um and yes you have uh but you know
there is money to be made i think
literally if you are someone who
understands how to process the details
you have a culture people who who are
told oh trust your instinct you'll make
great judgments well look i love playing
against those people at the poker table
right you know in the long run me or
other players who are even better than
me
will take will take their money the guy
who kind of wanders in and says well i
can read your soul and tell that you
have only a pair of sevens right um like
there are a few people maybe 100 people
who can really have very good ability to
read other people's tells and emotions
but for the most part they're just
they're just fooling themselves it's
much less about that than we've been led
to believe in
[Music]
james bond's casino royale yeah coker
it's mostly so most of the reading that
you're doing what poker players call ham
reading is just making logical
inferences based on well you know you
raised now and then you just called you
probably had a good hand and some card
made you scared that i had a flush say
right so you can narrow down the
probabilities a lot just based on on
people's betting patterns um the way
they might be behaving uh might give you
a few clues at the margin but remember
good poker players um they'll either be
there they'll either have good poker
faces or they can give off false tells
right um and so you have a whole cat and
mouse game and and for the most part um
following the the kind of math
mathematical logic of it is probably
it's probably 90 percent of it the the
reading someone physically is is uh is
worth something you look for any edge
you can get but it's probably 10 of it
at most
uh clearly a lot of things you're
passionate about passionate about sports
you love poker um
and you read your book and you realize
oh this guy this also guy really enjoys
math
we differ on that one but
uh
are you passionate about politics do you
do do you vote do you care about
politics i didn't um
you know i have my political preferences
i haven't voted since i joined the new
york times which is not a company policy
by the way it's just my kind of personal
a personal choice and if i'm writing
about this event that i don't want to
simultaneously participate in that event
right um so
uh so you didn't vote i didn't vote no
no i'm i'm not a likely voter or if if a
pollster called me they would have to i
would have to
hang up right so like i don't plan to
vote this year you could tell them i'm
nate silver
i'm not voting no
i'm not voting but i'll tell you who
will win
uh i'll tell you exactly who will win um
we have a question here from
um
it's a new thing called the internet oh
wow don't get scared it's gonna be fine
this is uh a telon from twitter
asks which prediction from your career
was the least accurate
one that you got completely
wrong
we tried to predict the uh the uk
election in 2010 or 2011 i think it was
2010 i think it was and we had um the
liberal democrats doing well and the
tories
doing well there was kind of this big
surge toward toward labor at the end so
that didn't go all that well and how
much of it is a cultural difference
where you're unfamiliar with
the english people you're unfamiliar
with
their habits their mannerisms how to
read them their personality is that
where you think you you went awry i'm
not sure if there was that much of it
but they have a they have a multi-party
system there right and the multi-party
races if you people remember ross perot
in 92 that race had some crazy ups and
downs where um where perrault kept
dropping in and coming back out he was
actually ahead for a while right because
these big shifts and people are have
multiple choice you have more different
vectors by which the vote can move and
that's what happened in the uk is you
had um the liberal democrats basically
were this uh kind of centrist party and
at the end people were like well they're
not going to win right so they migrated
back to their camps and uh and that made
our predictions look pretty foolish in
the end um how much does a third party
candidate
change things for you does it does it
does it throw your models out the window
how much harder is it a lot higher to
model yeah if we had to truly be very
exciting right it's an interesting
problem um but one reason why the
primaries in the early stages like the
iowa caucus is so unpredictable because
you have six different candidates right
and you have republicans or democrats
right and they're all within the same
party right so um so it takes almost
nothing to move someone's vote and it's
really only in the few days before um a
primary actually one thing this year is
that in i think seven of the first eight
primary states for republicans the
candidate who was leading the polls a
week before actually lost right um you
almost want to kind of peak at the right
time yeah um because once you start
losing momentum and the press piles are
only other candidates pile on you can
kind of think of you know newt gingrich
basically being a
pinata for for the other candidates in
the press for at a couple different
points during the campaign um things can
turn sour very very quickly right so
it's when you're it's when you hit your
stride that's important as as hitting
your stride at all it's just as
important probably yeah i mean a lot of
it has to do with the with the timing of
it and in some ways though by the way
primaries are are the better tasks
because you have to perform consistently
right um where you can't just win one
state um and then be elected where you
have to
survive rough periods during the
campaign i think one thing that that uh
that frankly hurt romney is that you
know he was he was playing the jv league
during the republican primaries right
you did not have a lot of their better
more capable candidates enter you did
not have a christie or mitch daniels or
a paul ryan for that matter or a jeb
bush rick perry
seemed to have a lot of financial muscle
and then uh and then just didn't quite
work as a candidate right for a lot of
reasons he didn't have to play his a
game until he didn't have to play his a
game as much whereas obama did i mean of
the of the kind of three um
wins that obama has had meaning beating
hillary clinton in the primaries beating
mccain and beating romney it's still
that first one that was the most
impressive i think by by some margin
beating hillary all right well uh the
book is the signal and the noise why so
many predictions fail
uh but some don't and uh it is
fascinating stuff and nate i'm really
glad
the odds of you coming here i calculated
being one in nine so i'm the big winner
here i wish i'd put money on it cool but
uh thanks so much for being here thank
you conan yeah really cool having you on
the show uh that was jibber jabber
see you later